so can you tell us a little about the
meatball sub why is that a sandwich
that's so dear to your heart
what do you mean why why do you always
order I've noticed that you order it
from almost every restaurant you go to
it's well I mean
I I have to say I don't know I'm gonna
just let's break it down okay I don't
like meatballs on its own correct
because he doesn't like ground meat like
when I make like a burger like no and
anytime I've made like Gina Ling or
anything like that he's just like I
don't like do whatever she makes
ding-a-ling
eight ding-a-lings
I don't know I don't know and then um
and and but I like uh Reds the pasta
sauce you do right I like cheese yeah
and I like the type of bread which is
like uh French or yeah
[Laughter]
but I I so but I don't know it's one of
those things where it's like the
combination of all of it yeah I love
on its own not so much so I don't know
but I just love the flavor of it you
like every in fact I want to get one
today well you had one just two days ago
I know I love them yeah and I think can
I be honest with unless this pot belly
has one of the I know hot why why
because when I was in Chicago once
I was with Ike baronholtz and he was
like we were like we needed a meal
really quickly and he goes let's go to
Papa I never heard of it back then this
is 20 years ago and I go
um
I don't want to go to a fast food
because you'll like it so I was just out
of protest I go I'm gonna get the thing
that I don't think I'm gonna like which
is the meatball sandwich it was the best
I can still remember the sandwich today
same with omelets in France I had a
omelette and Fran I hated omelets before
that but when you have a good one it
gets you hooked so that was my beginning
with meatball sandwiches wow
it's a great history thank you mine is a
little different mine is a longanisa
Burger I don't know what you know
longanisa is it's a Filipino like
sausage yeah you got the egg on top it's
a very comforting food for me I ate it a
lot when I was a dumb drunk in my 20s
yeah it was like the food that would
like soak up the alcohol for me but yeah
that's my story is there duck in it
it's your beef with dog why do you hate
duck so much you don't eat duck man you
ate duck in the Philippines when we were
there we had a duck egg actually a baby
duck yeah I know and repeat it you had
balot and you had a real duck at Mott
32.
that's true you hate duck five ways I
didn't order it did I it came out
of where the kitchen uh the kitchen I
didn't order it I know if I if I'm gonna
okay here you chose the restaurant
specifically known for their duck I hear
his his uh his he's trying to argue that
this is my argument he didn't order it
but he had to eat it because it was
there because it's a fancy restaurant
they have it and then I go out it's if I
was at that restaurant they go here's a
meerkat
I would eat like a slice of the cheek or
whatever just to try and I'd be like I
don't like it's too dry yeah yeah but
what happens when you I saw you eat
multiple pieces and I think he has like
a philosophical problem with ducks
because I think you think they're
rapists no
no what yeah
rapist I'd love to hear this Theory no
no I don't know much about that you know
and so let's not cancel the duck right
now
all right hey dog world sorry because of
Donald Duck it's because of they're so
associated with cartoon characters Daffy
like Daffy and Donald right that I just
and also they're cute
I think cuteness has I think the reason
why the Panda's never been eaten is
because of just aesthetically they're
cute but they could be delicious that's
all that fat
you know I mean they could be the most
delicious thing in the world but you
would never eat one because they're just
too damn cute and the people Club seals
seals are cute
who clubs seals
people seal and like whale and all this
stuff is like uh you know it's a certain
cultures eat it right I I I I if I was
the president of the world
okay they have those if they had one
right and anybody clubbed a seal they
would be death row yeah that's dumb why
because sometimes that's the only
protein source for a lot of people okay
if you're a viking then you can do it
like if you're in a Nordic place you
know how they do in the Nordic places
yeah yeah how they like hang whales and
they eat the blubber or whatever yeah
paint that picture I don't know much
about it but you know I think I saw it
in the North or something
north of a great movie but um I don't
think they did it yeah let's move on um
but thank you so much for this is
painting those amazing thank you also
don't get let's let's not [__] these up
I want to pray in these yeah and he's
gonna print bigger ones for you guys to
play on the wall as well so he likes us
he doesn't do other podcasts no I think
you guys might be the first podcast yeah
oh that's so nice uh would you guys like
to I just want to also add uh you know
when I was on the road with Andrew
um some